SOME OF WHOM VIEW RUSSIA AS AN
EXISTENTIAL THREAT.
>> YOU HAVE SOME EXCLUSIVE
REPORTING ABOUT RUSSIAN
MERCENARIES IN THE CENTRAL
AFRICAN REPUBLIC FACING MULTIPLE
ALLEGATIONS OF WAR CRIMES
INCLUDING TORTURE, RAPE AND
MURDER.
WHAT ELSE DID YOU LEARN?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
IT'S NO SECRET THAT RUSSIAN
MERCENARIES ARE ACTIVE IN HALF A
DOZEN COUNTIES AROUND THE
WORLD.
THEY MAY BE GUILTY OF WAR
CRIMES.
WE WANTED TO TRAVEL TO THE
CENTRAL AFRICA REPUBLIC BUT
REFUSED ACCESS ON THE GROUNDS OF
OUR PREVIOUS REPORTING ON THE
PRESIDENT THERE.
WE SENT SOMEONE TO INTERVIEW
WITNESSES AND VICTIMS OF THESE
CRIMES.
WE HAD TO CHANGE THEIR NAME AND
DISGUISE THEIR FACES.
I DO WANT TO WARN VIEWERS THAT
SOME OF THIS MATERIAL THE
GRAPHIC.
>> Reporter: THE AFTERMATH AT A
MASSACRE IN THE MOSQUE IN THE
CENTRAL AFRICA REPUBLIC.
AT LEAST, 12 BODIES ARE VISIBLE
ON THE GROUND.
A WOMAN AND A CHILD ARE AMONG
THE DEAD.
DOZENS OF CIVILIANS HAD TAKEN
SHELTER IN THE MOSQUE THAT DAY
AFTER WITNESSES SAY RUSSIAN
MERCENARIES AND GOVERNMENT
TROOPS CAME HUNTING FOR REBEL
FIGHTERS.
HE WAS INSIDE THE MOSQUE BUT
INSTEAD OF FINDING SANCTUARY P
HE TOLD CNN THEY BECAME TARGETS.
>> THEY ASKED US THE TAKE THE
WOMEN AND CHILDREN OUT OF THE
MOSQUE.
SIX OF US WALKED OUT WITH OUR
HANDS RAISED.
THEY SEARCHED US AND FOUND
NOTHING.
WE HAD NOT GONE FIVE METERS WHEN
THEY STARTED SHOOTING US.
I WAS SHOT IN THE RIGHT FOOT.
>> Reporter: THAT SAME DAY HER
15-YEAR-OLD SON WAS KILLED BY
RUSSIANS FIRING FROM THE
HELICOPTER WHEN HE HUSBAND WENT
OUT FIND HIM, HE WAS SHOT DOWN
TOO.
>> MY HUSBAND WAS BURIED
TOGETHER WITH MY 15-YEAR-OLD
SON.
WHEN THE BURIAL WAS OVER, WE
COULDN'T SAY A WORD.
I WAS CRYING.
MY CHILDREN ALSO CAME NEXT TO ME
WAILING.
IT WAS THE RUSSIANS WHO KILLED
MY HUSBAND LEAVING ME WITH
CHILDREN IN PAIN.
>> Reporter: A CONFIDENTIAL U.N.
REPORT FOUND THAT ABUSES WERE
CARRIED OUT ON BOTH SIDES BUT
THE RUSSIANS MAY HAVE COMMITTED
WAR CRIMES AND IT DOES NOT
APPEAR TO BE AN ISOLATED
INCIDENT.
OVER SEVERAL MONTHS, CNN AND THE
INDEPENDENT GROUP HAVE OBTAINED
TESTIMONY AND DOCUMENTS
IMPLICATING RUSSIAN CONTRACTORS
DEPLOYED TO TRAIN THE CENTRAL
AFRICAN ARMY IN WIDE RANGE OF
ATROCIIES DURING FIGHTING
BETWEEN GOVERNMENT AND REBEL
FORCES, INCLUDING MASS
SHOOTINGS, TORTURE AND THE
BURNING OF VILLAGES.
IN MARCH, IT SENT DETAILS OF
ALLEGED ABUSES TO THE RUSSIAN
AND CENTRAL AFRICA GOVERNMENTS.
>> BRAVE HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES
INCLUDING RAPE, SUMMARY
EXECUTION, TARGETED KILLINGS,
TORTURE, FORCED DISAPPEARANCE,
MURDERS AND OTHER ABUSES.
WE'RE TALK ABOUT WAR CRIMES
HERE, POTENTIALLY, ARE WE NOT?
>> YES, WE ARE.
WE'RE SEEING SOME OF THE MOST
SERIOUS HUMAN RIGHTS VIOLATIONS
AND HUMANITARIAN LAW VIOLATIONS.
WE'RE SEEING THEM ON A
WIDESPREAD SCALE.
PEOPLE ON THE GROUND ARE
TERRIFIED.
>> Reporter: IT'S A STARK
CONTRAST FROM THE STORY RUSSIA
TELLS.
IN THIS RECENT MOVIE, TOURIST,
FUNDED BY A COMPANY ASSOCIATED
WITH THE RUSSIAN MERCENARIES,
THEY ARE LAUDED AS HEROIC
DEFENDERS WHO HAVE LIBERATED
CENTRAL AFRICA.
RUSSIA'S PRESENCE IN THIS WAR
TORN MINERAL RICH NATION HAS
ALWAYS BEEN CONTROVERSIAL.
EVEN AS IT HAS BALLOONED FROM
170 CONTRACTED TRAINERS IN 2017
TO AROUND 2300 NOW ACCORDING TO
A U.N. DOCUMENT WITH MORE THAN
30 BASES SPREAD OUT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
39-YEAR-OLD TEACHER SHOWS OUR
CAMERA THE SCARS FROM WOUNDS HE
SAYS WERE INFLICTED BY RUSSIAN
MERCENARIES AT AN OUTPOST.
THEY TOOK US TO THE RUSSIAN
BASE, TIED US UP WITH ROPE AND
STARTED TO TORTURE US.
THEY USED A BAYONET TO INJURE MY
LEFT FOOT DEEPLY.
THEIR ACTIONS WERE EVIL AND BAR
BARBARIC.
WE ARE SEEING A PATTERN OF
BEHAVIORS BY THESE RUSSIAN
CONTRACTORS.
THIS HAPPENED IN OTHER
COUNTRIES.
THIS HAPPENED IN LIBYA WHERE
RUSSIAN PRIVATE CONTRACTORS WERE
INVOLVED IN A VARIETY OF HUMAN
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS.
>> Reporter: FOR THE VICTIMS OF
THESE ALLEGED CRIMES, THERE IS
LITTLE HOPE FOR JUSTICE.
PRIVATE MILITARY CONTRACTORS ARE
TAKING ILLEGAL IN RUSSIA AND
DON'T OFFICIALLY EXIST.
MANY LOCALS LIVE IN FEAR OF
REPERCUSSIONS FROM A SHADOWY AND
UNACCOUNTABLE FORCE.N TRIED TO
MULTIPLE PEOPLE.
HE'S ALSO THE ARCHITECT OF THE
FAMOUS FACTORY INVOLVED IN THE
MEDDLING BACK IN 2016.
HE DID NOT RESPOND AND THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT DID NOT
RESPOND BUT THEY DID RESPOND TO
THE U.N. WORKING GROUP ON
MERCENARIES.
LETTERS OF ALLEGATIONS SAYING
THAT RUSSIAN AFRICA REPUBLIC AR
HARMED.